but let me ask this question it's uh
from important john
uh another great name uh he and his his
question really talks about
uh there's obviously a lot of what you
might call conspiracy theories floating
around at the moment the idea that you
know covert was created by bill gates
and all this other stuff uh and uh
heather i know that there are some
conspiracies which have now
increasingly turned out to be actually
true lab leak is something we'll be
talking with brett about on tuesday but
from a psychological perspective jordan
what is the
the appeal of a conspiratorial view of
the world why do why are people drawn to
conspiracies
i think it's often
a manifestation of low agreeableness
distrust
it's
it's simple and explanatory
so that's helpful
we tend to personify things
it's easy to see malevolence and intent
where there's just ignorance and
randomness
and because it's important to identify
malevolent intent we might have a
tendency to over perceive it especially
in the out group let's say
and then but i think there's additional
factors at play right now
like
it's not that easy to distinguish
conspiratorial thinking from just
creative thinking right
so there's something happens there's a
bunch of explanations why it might
happen
now you might have a cock-eyed
conspiratorial version and then you go
talk to your friends and your family and
they sort of tune you in but let's say
it's kovid and you're isolated
well you know
every one of us has got a proclivity
towards our own particular form of
insanity like we blow out at our weakest
point when we're stressed and the way
that we deal with that is by banging
ourselves up against other people it's
like what do you think of this i think
that's stupid oh
okay well maybe i'll have to go rethink
it well that's part of what keeps our
conspiratorial thinking
under wraps right we have to share it
with other people and and if they think
it's preposterous then we go back and
rethink it it's it's distributed
cognition in the social space
now you can find like-minded people for
your conspiracy instantly and they're
not even real people often they're
disembodied and and so we also have no
idea what that's doing to
so human social cognitive political
thinking
we don't know and that's another
consequence of this radical
transformation in technology we don't
even know what it does to people to have
to speak to
speak over video instead of in person
what that does to discourse we have no
idea what twitter does to thought you
have to compress your thought into you
know a minimum number of or maximum
number of characters well does that does
that bias you towards the expression of
impulsive aggression
kind of looks like it
you know does it increase the
probability that you're going to speak
out
kind of in the privacy of your own
cocoon like you're behind the wheel of
an automobile and shielded when
something irritates you could easily be
these are mass communication networks
with huge effects and we have no idea
about their
what they do to us psychologically
and we'll never figure it out because by
the time we study it they'll have
transformed into something completely
different
so it's it's tough it's a tough one
heather
i agree don't assume malevolence where
you can assume ignorance yeah that's a
good that's a good
mental hygiene
approach to conspiratorial thinking it's
probably stupidity
yeah i i agree with that uh and just
this isn't an
and also
not following from that but and also and
i know you're having a conversation as
you said with brad on tuesday
um
currently
alternative approaches to thinking
through what we are being told are being
branded as conspiracy as a way to shut
down the conversation right and so this
is you know
this is the death of science this is
exactly the same people who are branding
things conspiracy theory are saying
hashtag follow the science and these
aren't people who would recognize a
hypothesis that was alternative to the
only one that they're allowing us to
talk about if it didn't face
so
um you know there's a weaponization of
words
uh you know again um but specifically
you know as of
5 10 years ago we all knew that we were
most afraid of being called racist
and now uh it's understood that you
certainly don't want to be called a
conspiracy theorist but hey remember
that every big idea and probably most of
the small ones too that we now
understand to be true
were once promoted by one or a couple of
people and they were roundly mocked and
perhaps stigmatized and perhaps even
ostracized or even executed for even
saying the thing and so yes lab leak is
a perfect example and there are more in
coveted space and there are more all the
time and what social media does is it
gives the bullhorn to the
to the orthodoxy to those who are
claiming they have no power at all but
actually have the power to shout down
any dissent to the raiding
the reigning narrative
that you know if you look at the way
science works you think about it this
way
well many well-meaning people doing
everything they possibly can to rein
their egos in generate hypotheses about
why something happens
99 out of 100 times they're
wrong
right and now if you're right one
percent of the time and that's
cumulative man you're just your
knowledge is progressing so damn fast
you can't even keep up with it but your
error rate is still 99 and that's with
the best method we possibly have to
detect you know some some facet of the
truth in the political space well it's
much harder so the error rate is going
to be much much greater
and so
and of course everybody's tails it not
because they've been locked down for a
year and a half and god only knows how
insane we are because of that and what
the consequence of that's going to be i
mean i certainly don't think that
the lockdown is going to result in a net
in net life saving i doubt that very
much
we'll probably never have the data and i
can understand that
the western world and the rest of the
world for that matter didn't want to see
their medical system completely swamped
but
but
i doubt very much that we saved people
we'll see i don't know i don't know
we saved some people at the cost of
others is what you mean we saved some
people in the short term at the cost of
many others in the long run
and and look those sorts of trade-offs
we make those sorts of trade-offs
because that immediately evident
catastrophe mortality is a lot more
difficult to deal with psychologically
than you know a five percent increase in
the rate of alcoholism or something like
that which is basically invisible i'm
not castigating the people who did this
well the people who did that this were
us so castigate away
[Music]
you